this is crazy I was in high school I was
living with my dad I was 15 or 16. yes
my dad rents out the other two rooms two
roommates From This Moment On take your
time
one lady couldn't make rent my dad told
me he's gonna kick her out like next
week or whatever five in the morning she
comes and knocks on my door she comes
huh she goes your dad's gonna kick me
out is there anything I can do for you
to convince him to let me stay whoa and
I was like what's your age difference at
this point I don't know she was nasty
though oh I think she had double D's I
think oh that's not bad she was like
probably like 40. oh what 40 is kind of
hot still okay 99 Ranch like one of
those ladies so I was like [__] close
the door I'm like this is [__] you
just close the door how come she didn't
do that to your dad maybe she did I
don't know I tried my son I don't know
try that guy he's a [__] person you
couldn't tell she's trying to be
seductive in as much as a 99 Ranch lady
Can Be You Can Tell She's trying to be
seductive
in French